Speaker 1: I told you yesterday or the day before
or like three weeks ago. I don't know. Time flies
that Donald Trump had one last chance left to
prevent his tax returns from being released to
the House committee investigating him. And that
last opportunity was an appeal to the highest
court of the land, the Supreme Court, a very right
wing court in 2022. The Supreme Court has decided
to pray at the altar of Trump. And indeed, Judge
Justice John Roberts has delayed the handover of
Donald Trump's taxes to that House panel. This was
the last arrow in the quiver that Trump had left,
and indeed it is on target, at
least temporarily. The Associated
Press reporting Roberts delays handover of
Trump tax returns to House panel. Amazing,
right? But maybe not totally surprising. Chief
Justice John Roberts on Tuesday put a temporary
hold on the handover of Trump's tax returns
to the congressional committee. Roberts order
gives the Supreme Court time to weigh the
legal issues. And Trump's emergency appeal
to the high court filed Monday. Without court
intervention, the tax returns could have been
provided as early as Thursday by the Treasury
Department to the Democratically controlled
House Ways and Means Committee. Roberts gave the
committee until wait a second, November 10th.
Why is that an important date? Let me think.
November 10th. Oh, there's an election on November
8th. Very interesting. The chief justice handles
emergency appeals from the nation's capital, where
the fight over Trump's taxes has been going on
since 2019, writes the Associated Press. Remember,
lower courts ruled that the committee has
broad authority to obtain tax returns and
rejected Trump's claim that it was overstepping.
This is is are we shocked by this? CNBC also
reporting Supreme Court temporarily blocks
Congress from getting Trump's tax returns.
A very, very similar report from CNBC. What
exactly is going to happen with this? Because
for years the House Ways and Means Committee,
which has absolutely appropriate, constitutionally
indicated investigative responsibilities,
not just abilities but responsibilities,
has been doing everything correctly and trying to
get a hold of these taxes. They've done everything
and it's appeal and obstruct and block if indeed
at this point, Donald Trump didn't think that
there was going to be something damaging to him in
those tax returns, why would he still be working
this hard to block their release? What also, by
the way, is the constitutional question that the
Supreme Court needs to weigh and think about where
every other judge and court so far has said no,
there's no good argument here. The House has broad
authority to obtain tax returns. They are doing
everything correctly. They should be turned over.
Every single court has found that in every venue
that Donald Trump has figured out how to pull into
this mess. But the Supreme Court now needs time
until just 36 hours after the midterm elections
to figure out whether this is actually appropriate
or not. November 10th for the committee to reply
What is the purpose of the block? What determines
whether the block stays and how long does it
actually last? Is this just a brazen attempt
to get beyond the November 8th election without
the tax returns being released, no matter what
is in there, just on the off chance that there's
something damaging to Trump or Republicans there,
could the Supreme Court be that biased
politically to the right, given that it has
three Trump s judges on it, even though this was
the decision of a justice not selected by Donald
Trump? Chief Justice John Roberts At this point,
I genuinely don't know. But when you read Sober
Political. The Eagle analyzes of this. All of
those analyzes come to the conclusion that at
the end of the day, the tax returns should be
given to the House Ways and Means Committee.
Whether they will find anything noteworthy
there remains to be seen. As a reminder,
three most likely elements that would come
from a full review of Donald Trump's tax
returns if indeed they are provided in full and
unredacted, would be number one. Trump's not as
wealthy as he claims to be. We basically know that
already, but it would be confirmation. Number two,
it would confirm what Michael Cohen and
others have been saying for a long time,
that for tax purposes, Trump undervalues assets,
that he's separately overvalued when they are
to be used for collateral purposes. That would be
number two. And then, I mean, and we could go even
further. There's many other things I won't repeat
to you the entire list. But the point here is the
things we are likely to learn would not come as
an insane shock, but they would be confirmation
of what we've suspected for a long time. Also,
I guess I should mention that Donald Trump has
business with shady characters. That would be
another. And how would we learn that? Well, he may
list assets on tax returns, which we could then
cross-reference to other owners or other business
entities that are involved in the ownership of the
very same assets. It would show that Trump is in
business with people we didn't know about or that
he sought to downplay or whatever the case may be.
Do I believe that ultimately the House committee
will get the tax returns? I do. And by the way,
I expect them to leak once the House committee
gets them. But it could take a little bit longer.